golden age of Indian chess and it's all
because of one man vishwanathan Anand
today we're outside the home of Aruna
and vishyanan to get a peek into their
life let's go
Hi how are you it's lovely to see you
thank you
[Music]
yeah this is the special room so let's
see who's there inside
hi hello
is this the famous room where when India
has a new Grand Master there is a
tradition that we've heard about he's
invited to your home is this where
it happens yes we obviously they're
allowed to sit there as well but
invariably they want to come in and have
a look and then I think there are
pictures of Prague coming
what are the conversations that happen
here with the young kids
usually we get very quickly many of them
are tongue-tied so we usually we get
very quickly to why don't you show me
your last game man then they open up a
lot
there is an X Factor there is something
unknown take our own golden generation
if you like
I mean I selected them because it's
obviously ridiculously talented some
people just have an attitude which is uh
like Magnus his Ascent was so fast how
do you really explain it
I might sense that someone is very good
but still when it happens it usually
catches me off guard when did I have
when you know when did they become this
strong
on
for the India number one he's a student
of the Westbridge on and chess Academy
how do you feel about that I feel very
proud and definitely you know
I was able to give gokesh a lot of
suggestions a lot of advice I'm not
really his coach but interacted with
them a lot and things like that with
Prague as well I've interacted quite a
bit clearly they have their own
long-suffering parents they have their
coaches and things like that but we're
able to chip in so I feel very proud
it's also partially a relief how long do
you want to be waiting for this to
happen and that's the thing about being
semi-retired is that you're much more
detached of it personally
um but it is still a shock that
to realize that something you expected
to happen eventually and you never
defined eventually in your mind
eventually means eventually
when it finally happens it's
you feel funny in your own skin let's
put it that way
you're not sure what's different and
something is different in the air
[Music]
this is arnon's first ever mention in a
newspaper
you were in those first Grand Master
today India has 83 Grand Masters the
biggest talents are coming from the
country and for most of them if not all
You're the Inspiration what does it mean
to you the impact that your success has
had on Indian chess I feel quite proud
that
let's say in just first up started up
here in the newspapers and in the media
because of my play and then there was
this long period throughout the 90s and
even the zeros where
I was competing for the world title
competing in the best tournaments and so
on and
it just really started up here in the
media and you felt this is going to
produce a result already you could see
that
um people are starting academies and
towns doing a lot of coaching children's
competitions running out of space in
Halls to play this sort of thing there
were some anecdotal stuff and then
slowly the number of Grandmasters
started to pick up anyway over time you
get the sense that you're having an
impact and
you realize that the sport has grown a
lot
but that's my world junior
87 it's difficult to
tell you how many doors that open for me
what does the future look like for you
and how much more of competitive chess
you have left in you I figure when I
have had enough accomplishes I'll know
competitive chess I'll know and then
I'll take it then I don't imagine it
being too long I feel I'm in a very good
place now you get to a point in life
where all the things that once seemed
very Central you managed to put them in
their proper place and that's also very
relaxing
the other nice thing is
I feel like I can experiment with many
things now there's no pressure on me and
I can just do this just because it's
nice to try yeah I can't complain I am
very happy most of the time I'm very
very happy